so she's up in the sky lounge
she strips down half naked to her
underwear
jumps off the side of the boat and swims
away
and i'm going you can't make
hi i'm captain lee from below deck and i
am playing
never have i ever
no doubt it was season one actually and
i
really really did not want to finish out
this dinner
in fact i probably was 30 seconds away
from throwing these people off the boat
just undoing the lines taking them back
to the dock and saying
get that out of here the dinner
conversation was just so
obnoxious and grotesque one one of the
people at dinner actually
got up and took her knife
because a button was defending her
posterior
she pulled it up cut it off and threw it
overboard
it's a thousand dollar cushion and i
looked at the primary and i said
you just spent a grand and i was i was
that close to just
pitching it all
i think uh my crewmates dating
i'm not a huge fan of that and one of
the reasons
is because it's a very short-term
relationship
they may last the whole season but odds
are
they're going to get in trouble before
that occurs and then i'm either going to
have to fire one of them
or both of them because the other one's
going to get all butthurt
because you're fired by lover and i'm
going like
you're not doing your job have you ever
actually
had to fire someone for this oh
absolutely
in fact it was chef leon in season
two i think and i told him that you know
this would be our last charter together
because it just wasn't working out
and we only had two meals left to go and
he just said
i don't care i'm out of here right now
i'm not even gonna finish this
he went back so there we are with the
charter gas
and going like all right now what do i
do
i don't have a chef and so one of the uh
it was rocky she took extreme exception
to her
friend leon leaving so she's up in the
sky lounge
she strips down half naked to her
underwear
jumps off the side of the boat and swims
away
and i'm going you can't make
i have gone down the slide i mean you
have to
it can be quite intimidating if you've
never done it before and
you do pick up a lot of speed but the
one thing that you definitely have to do
is remember to soak it up good
and if it's not wet and if it's not
soaked up you're just gonna go down
going
all the way down and then you've got
these little burns on your
that's happened it happened with kate
and
it was her first season on board and we
had dean's lover on board
and he had made a comment to kate about
uh
she wasn't smiling enough to suit him
and i'd get where kate was
she does have a resting case and he said
you know
honestly katie just really come off as
kind of
she took exception to it i came out for
to see these guys at breakfast
i said dean how's it going every that
there's been good so far
and he said yeah he said i had this uh
this unique uh
towel design on my uh on my bed this
morning and i said really
and he said yeah he said somebody left
this like four foot penis on my bed
i i didn't know what to say
i was totally blindsided had no idea
that was coming
and i'm just like i'll uh can i look
into that and get back to you
he said please too
yeah it's uh you would be surprised when
people are capable
capable of behind the anonymity of a
keyboard
and you you think you know you hear
stories about that stuff but you don't
think it's going to happen to you and
then all of a sudden you
pop open your computer and
it's like seriously so
thank you for having me i have really
enjoyed playing the game
and the only thing we have left is now
the reunion which will air
next monday night i'm looking forward to
that there's going to be a lot of stuff
that's going to hit the fan
a lot want more fun stuff i thought so
check out these videos floating around
my head this one is really cool
i'm just saying no pressure